defying clouds of tear gas
and reports of live ammunition these
protesters
are tearing down concrete barriers their
aim
to reach the highly secured green zone
home to government offices and embassies
the iraqi human rights commission says
many protesters were injured after being
hit
with tear gas canisters as they faced
government forces on the sinai bridge
in central baghdad
it's the third night since a curfew was
imposed by the iraqi military
but the lockdown is largely ignored by
protesters
before the curfew these were the scenes
in tahrir square
an area that has become the symbol of an
uprising
that began in early october
till when will we stay like this we are
a nation that loves life
our country is rich you steal from us
we will remain steadfast men and women
together
these protesters are angry about high
unemployment
foreign meddling and domestic affairs
from the us and iran
and what they call top-level corruption
[Music]
we're in terrier square supporting our
sons brothers and friends
who are protesting to show a civilized
image to the world
we come to tahrir square every morning
to treat injured protesters
we mix water and yeast and distribute it
to people here
thousands of people are demonstrating in
major cities in iraq
including kabbalah najaf and basra
the government should make a real
serious
reform in the political system in the
electrical electoral
system also and you know
iraqis require real democracy ideal
democracy
as protesters call for prime minister
adul abdul mahdi to step down
his position is becoming increasingly
more fragile
shia cleric who leads parliament's
largest block
is also working towards removing him
over the past month scores of people
have been killed
and thousands injured and despite the
violence
some protesters created a festival
atmosphere
with some people playing dominoes others
dance and some offered free haircuts to
the crowd
the protesters have become increasingly
more diverse
with women and students joining the
crowds
laura bird and manly al jazeera